disney doesn't always bat a thousand
with outdated cultural references and
so-so films within its catalog
but not every movie the mouse house made
deserves a poor reputation
some worthy ones just happen to fly
under the radar
here are some of the best disney movies
you've probably never seen
disney's theatrical release of winnie
the pooh in 2011 was easy to dismiss as
a recycled retread
after all there had already been three
pooh movies since 2000
the tigger movie piglet's big movie and
pooh's heffalump movie
and none of those were that impressive
but this winnie the pooh is as sweet as
the honey-loving cubby stuffed with
fluff
it's also clever and gorgeous thanks to
a traditional hand-drawn animation from
walt disney animation studios
and inspiration from author a.a milne's
original stories
winnie the pooh spins a charming tale
where eeyore loses his
meanwhile the hundred acre wood friends
think a monster has abducted young
christopher robin
a good-hearted poo tries to help
everyone while his tummy rumbles for
honey like a character all its own
with wordplay literally rescuing these
friends and jokes that don't rely on pop
culture references
it's an all ages delight thank you all
ever so much
meet the robinsons came out in 2007
shortly after pixar's john lasseter took
over disney animation which led to a lot
of perhaps
unnecessary scrutiny and comparisons for
this film at the time
on its own merits it's a zippy family
sci-fi romp with heart and a marvelous
retro futuristic aesthetic
the story focuses on lewis a young
orphaned science prodigy who wants to
find the family he never knew
between creating inventions that are a
blast for all the wrong reasons
one day he meets a boy from the future
named wilbur
robinson what is it where are we going
to the future wilbur whisks lewis off to
save the day from a time traveling
baddie with world conquering ambitions a
surprisingly dangerous hat
and a secret connection to the past
lewis also meets wilbur's eccentric
extended family a swinging band of frogs
and a frustrated dinosaur henchman your
[Music]
hench-asaurus
[Music]
the way the time travel story comes full
circle at the end is one of the most
satisfying things about it so we won't
spoil that but as the title implies
meet the robinsons is all about the
timelessness of family
released in 2001 atlantis the lost
empire is a science fiction adventure
that
just didn't do what audiences expected
from a disney animated film
but it's worth rediscovering for
starters the production design of mike
mignola better known as the creator of
hellboy
gives the film a striking look that
ratchets up the cool factor of twenty
thousand leagues under the sea
the film also boasts a strong voice cast
led by michael j
fox as milo thatch a young researcher
and linguistics expert who finds the way
to the legendary undersea kingdom
even as everyone around mocks him for
believing that atlantis is real
with funding from an eccentric
millionaire milo joins an amusing group
of explorers including a demolitions
expert
a cracker jack female mechanic a
geologist who's like a human mole
a cook who thinks lard is a food group
and a daredevil leader
once the group finds atlantis the
architecture and lost civilization prove
enchanting as does the kingdom's
princess keita
a formidable warrior who doesn't look
one bit of 8 000 years old
by the way we were never properly
introduced my name is milo
my name is kiragakash
fox is adorably awkward his rapport with
keita is endearing and the story dips
into some strong themes around the
explorer's intrusion
it also features some stunning effects
showing that this underwater
civilization is anything but all wet
the backstory of 2011's mars needs moms
is confusing and that's even before we
get into the plot
the animation studio image movers
founded by director robert zemeckis
actually produced the film but disney
released it under a partnership with
image movers at the time
so it's at least partly a disney film
and one of the more offbeat entries
under the studio's name
based on a children's book by bloom
county cartoonist
berkeley breathed mars needs moms is
about a boy on earth
who races to stop martians from
extracting his mom's memories and
essence of mom-ness
to implanting their robot nannies
basically killing mom in the process
definitely dark and perhaps too much for
kids who find bambi and finding nemo to
intense
but older fans who enjoy the classic
sci-fi flair of the twilight zone might
appreciate its innovative twists
plus the zameka style of motion capture
based animation featured in films like
the polar express
actually works well with this film's
martian characters who are meant to look
inhuman even if you don't like the
overall result
it's worth checking out as a bold
creative leap
the title of john carter is likely one
reason this 2012 sci-fi adventure
escaped viewers orbit
it was originally meant to be john
carter of mars and launch a whole series
based around the books by edgar rice
burroughs
which director andrew stanton loved as a
child
but disney apparently decided to hide
the red planet part after the colossal
flop of 2011's mars needs moms
unfortunately that left people who
weren't familiar with the books
clueless that's too bad because john
carter is an old-fashioned epic
complete with monsters arena battles and
huge action set pieces with cities and
ships that soar through the air
based on the first john carter book a
princess of mars
the film tells the story of a civil war
veteran who finds himself teleported to
mars
where several races are battling for
domination
after being held prisoner carter falls
in with the four armed green
martians falls in love with the martian
princess
deja thorus and ultimately unites
several groups against a manipulative
order
lead couple taylor kitsch of friday
night lights fame and lynn collins have
playful dialogue and decent chemistry
possibly because they both appeared in
2009's x-men origins wolverine as gambit
and kayla silverfox
kitch also proved himself winsome enough
to be a big time action star
even though the film never took flight
at the box office like carter does
in mars gravity sky high did well enough
at the box office in 2005 but this fun
family comedy seemed to get lost between
tweenage viewers among that year's
batman begins
and fantastic four movies a young
michael angarano who plays nick pearson
on this is us is the main character will
stronghold
his parents are well known superheroes
the commander played by kurt russell
and jetstream played by kelly preston
will attend sky high where future heroes
and villains learn about sidekicks and
rescue strategies
but he doesn't appear to have any
superpowers landing him at the bottom of
the school's social order
when the teen uncovers a super villain's
plot he gains confidence and discovers
which friends he can trust
the humor in sky high also should make
any superhero fan smile
along with sly touches such as casting
tv's former wonder woman linda carter as
the school's principal
i am principal powers on behalf of all
the faculty and staff
welcome to sky high
treasure planet took robert louis
stevenson's classic 1880s pirate
adventure novel treasure island
and transplanted it to a steampunk
version of outer space
the 2002 film stars joseph gordon levitt
as jim hawkins
who develops a complex surrogate
father-son relationship with mutinous
pirate john
silver imagined here as a cyborg with a
laser scanning eye
silver first meets jim while cooking
with a robotic arm that's like a kitchen
swiss army tool
able to dice food as well as an enemy's
fingers
silver has a cute shape shifter pal
named morph a tiny blob that resembles a
pink cloud with eyes
and jim has a high-tech surfboard to
weave through canyons and around flying
pirate ships
filmmakers have adapted stevenson's tail
several times
even with muppets and sci-fi has plenty
of smugglers and scoundrels
so the futuristic twist isn't much of a
stretch but this gamble didn't pay off
at the box office
nevertheless treasure planet is a
rollicking propulsive adventure story
with spectacular visuals that combine
traditional animation and cgi
backgrounds
as well as evergreen themes about
finding one's family
disney's tarzan from 1999 won an oscar
for best original song
which is actually one of its least
memorable qualities
sure it has comic relief animal
sidekicks which some viewers may find
annoying and a noticeable lack of black
characters for a story set in africa
but it's an overall agreeable retelling
of the famous edgar riceborough story
about a man raised by apes who
encounters humans as an adult
and then has to decide where his
loyalties lie with the ape family who
nurtured him
or with other human beings much of the
story focuses on tarzan's romance with
jane porter
a proper 1911 english gal and the
humorous and sometimes breathless voice
work from
minnie driver is a highlight i was saved
i was saved by a flying wild man in a
loincloth good lord but there are also
touching moments between tarzan and his
eight mom
kala who teaches young tarzan that as
different as they seem on the outside
their hearts care the same animation
fans will appreciate that animators
modeled tarzan's movements through the
trees after extreme sports athletes
i've been watching my son do his
skateboarding and snowboarding and
started thinking of tarzan as kind of
having this attitude of like a
surfer kind of a guy plus the jungle
looks every bit as lush
enticing and dangerous as it should if
you're not in the mood for the jungle
book
give this a swing victor hugo's novel
the hunchback of notre dame was always a
strange choice for an animated disney
film
it's a grim story with a strong sexual
element
and no small amount of death disney gave
this tale a relatively happy ending
along with fun songs and a trio of
talking gargoyles
but the story still has a lot of
darkness around the edges that took
audiences by surprise when the film was
released in 1996.
however those oddities make it an
interesting watch
especially for older viewers plus the
hunchback of notre dame has frollo one
of the wickedest disney villains of all
time
frollo is the local minister of justice
but he's pure
evil developing a lustful obsession with
esmeralda
the romani dancer who befriends the
humble quasimodo
the hunchback who has lived inside notre
dame cathedral in paris since he was a
baby
frollo basically wants to wipe out the
romani people of paris
and tries to control esmerelda before
attempting to burn her at the stake
meanwhile quasimodo and a heroic soldier
named phoebus attempt to stop his plans
it's not quite hugo's original but it's
still a complex and compelling take
with an unlikely hero who finds courage
and acceptance
the idea of updating fantasia goes back
to the release of the original 1940 film
which walt disney wanted to re-release
regularly with new segments replacing
older ones
so the movie would constantly change and
evolve unfortunately the original
fantasia lost money upon its initial
release
which nixed walt's plans of doing more
however the concept was revived in the
90s and this sequel ended up coming
together just in time to celebrate the
new millennium
fantasia 2000 includes the well-known
sorcerer's apprentice sequence from the
original film
along with new segments such as pines of
rome featuring flying whales and pomp
and circumstance
where donald duck has to help noah lead
animals to the ark
a standout is rhapsody in blue an
evocative new york story set to
gershwin's jazzy composition
and animated in the style of
caricaturist al hirschfeld
it's unlike anything else in either film
and distinctive among disney productions
in general
the beloved 1962 fantasy novel a wrinkle
in time by madeleine
l'engle was considered unfilmable for
decades because of its space-time
distortions
shape-shifting aliens peculiar
landscapes
but acclaimed director eva duvernay
brought it to life in 2018 with the help
of modern digital effects
an appealing young protagonist named meg
played by storm reed
and the impressive trio of reese
witherspoon mindy kaling
and oprah winfrey as the cosmic beings
who assist her in finding her lost
father
played by chris pine some of the plot
proved
too complicated some might say
convoluted for viewers
and the film's mix of sci-fi and
children's lit is an unusual fit
but those surreal vistas that might have
been tough to imagine are sights to see
and the story of a character finding a
strength and power that she didn't know
she had
is as relevant as ever check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite disney films and characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]